Hello everyone and welcome to the Grand Prixquel podcast. This week we are going to be discussing
rumors as for the feeder series grid for next year. It's looking right from F2 all the way
down to F4. Your hosts for this week are myself, Peter, Nova and Alex. I say let's just dive
right into it but we just want to give a bit of a warning before we start talking. We are not
actual journalists. We do not know, we don't actually know anything and all of our information
is mainly from Twitter from like Percy and Illan. So if we're wrong, please don't blame us. And we
can- testing, if a driver’s testing with a team, they can always mean they're signing but maybe
this is an experience. So yeah, none of what we're saying is like, don't take it as the truth,
please. Yeah, in F2, I think the Invicta lineup page, I mean, we've known Freddie Slater is going
to be with them for over a year. We knew after he won FREC. It was rumored that he signed with
Trident and then Invicta for the year after. This is an open secret. I mean, it was so funny
before even F3 started. Yeah, for 2027, you know, he's already signed a pre-contract.
Like, you know what, all right. But also that's got to be some, you know, balls move because
you're just signaling, I know that I'm going to do well. I respect that. And he is doing well.
He's getting the title fight in F3. He's the championship leader. And F2, we're going to hear
him again fighting for the title. And the second seat is rumored to be Noel Leon, which on the
Invicta second seat always seems to be somebody random. But I feel like he's actually doing too
good for the seat. But the Invicta second seat is usually a lot of money. But it's often like a
driver who's, if we look back, it's a driver who, you know, there was, we had money with Durksen now,
I think Stanek kind of falls out of that because he doesn't have that much money.
But they all kind of have in common that they cannot really even get close to match the main
driver of the team. Yeah. And looking at the camp box lineup, it feels like we're going to have a
repeat of the F3 title fight next year with Ugochukwu going towards Campos.
I think this honestly depends on what Red Bull does, because there are rumours that they are
looking at like both Ugochukwu and Theophile Nael. So since we all know Campos is kind of the Red
Bull junior team, I think if one of them is signed, it's a definite sign that they will do it with,
that they will do F2 with Campos. But I could see all current Campos drivers do the step up.
Oh yeah, they're all ready for it. They've all been quite good. And I feel like with something
like Nael, the results maybe don't show it, but pace wise, he's been right up there. And
yeah, one of them or Nael will partner Ugo, I reckon. Just don't know who. And for Ugo,
there have been rumours of F1 in- I feel I think Cadillac are obviously interested,
which makes sense, because America. As long as Cadillac doesn't send him to
Hitech, everything's fine. Oh no, not Hitech. Yeah, and speaking of Hitech,
yeah, it's always a question. There's Colton continuing one for another season.
I mean, nothing much has been said, I think. I'm just thinking back, but also I think with
the Super License point, at some point they would like to expire, you know? So I think if he like
throws, since I don't think he's getting, anyways, that much in 2026, he will have to do even better.
And at this point, I wouldn't do it, but we don't know what kind of money is behind there.
Yeah, like if I were him and money wasn't an issue, I'd just get more Super License points
by doing free practices this year and be in F1 next year, especially with, yeah, with
Bottas's seats being uncertain. That's probably what he may try to do, but, and alongside the
other seats, if he calls, he's going to be Nakamura, because you have the Hitech and
TGR relationship. It just kind of makes sense. Generally, at AIX, we are really used to one
thing, and that is drivers no one would really expect in F2. I mean, Shields will probably be
there again, and, you know, I go with all the rumors, because he does give me the vibe of
someone who just stays in the series for way too long. But other than that, I don't think
we have had anyone really announced, or like not announced, but like anyone who
shows up and feels spiritually AIX.
Yeah, and the second AIX seat, we did see a Percy Wolf predicting Neto for that seat.
What the hell?
Oh, goodness. He's...
I mean, he would not be the first driver that goes straight to AIX after skipping.
Yeah, seems to be a pattern. I mean, we didn't know AIX is going to be just that team with
the most random lineup ever, who would just basically whoever has money, as Alex said,
is going to be in this team.
Or whether it does not have money sometimes and just ends up here.
Yeah, there's two extremes of being, and of course I read Taylor Barnard a few years ago.
My man.
Anyways, I think what I saw a lot of people report on and what I do also believe is that
the F3 grid is closer to being filled than the F2 grid, which comes with the fact that,
you know, F3 is nearing its end. I think the last race is somewhere in September.
I think we only have two rounds left.
Yep, only Monza and Madrid!
Madring!
I refuse that.
Anyways, what I'm trying to say is most drivers in F3 already know where they end up in the
championship. So they know if they, you know, repeat the year, if they have to, you know,
leave the championship, if they can go to F2. And most, you know, Formula Regional champions also
kind of know if, you know, it'll be enough to step up next year. And so,
F3 is really full, but F2 is still quite uncertain because, to be honest, I don't even know how many
rounds we're driving this year because I still do not believe that we're going to drive Abu Dhabi.
I mean, it would be nice if everyone was safe and, you know, no one was getting hurt and so
we could drive Abu Dhabi. But at the moment, it does not look that way, sadly, and
I'm really confused about it.
Yeah, we'll probably see just the round replaced because it looks like
F1 are going to go race in Europe. So I wouldn't be surprised if F2 just follow them there.
Yeah, but either ways, F2 still has quite a few things open. And we also have situations like
Tsolov who's uncertain if he's going to make the step up to F1, if he's going to be sent elsewhere
like Red Bull used to do, or, you know, if he has to do another year because, I don't know,
he magically lost the title really embarrassingly. I would not repeat the year in that case, but like.
Also, I imagine we'll see some F3 drivers moving in some F2 races end of the year,
which gives more of an idea as well, as we always see. But yeah, moving on to the F3 grid.
I mean, with Trident, we've had Sebastian Wheldon posting himself
posting Trident F3 on a TikTok story of all places.
Great, thank you. I need every single driver to take the page out of his book. Please,
all just do it like this.
So, I mean, this is a big indication I think he's going to be with Trident, which makes sense.
He's a driver who's calibrated for a title, and alongside him,
KNB seems very inevitable as well. I mean, this may be the pipeline of Prema FREC to Trident F3,
Kamara, Freddy, and now KNB. This makes if KNB wins the title,
it could get some really weird sort of pipeline of Prema FREC champion to Trident F3 champion.
But we will see next year.
But I think it will be fascinating, because this far, I cannot remember Trident managing
two cars at the same time. I mean, if I think back, it's also been a while,
so please correct me if I'm wrong.
But also when we had Fornaroli and Camara and now Slater, like even if they have solid teammates,
there's no one that can, you know, match up with him.
And I'm unsure how, because I remember last year, there was quite a bit of drama because
Um, I don't know which one was- there’s multiple, I don't know which one it was, but I remember there was a bit of drama,
because it was expected of him to follow like team orders and, you know, don't attack Camara.
And it happened multiple times.
Well, that's certainly not happening this year.
That has not happened this year, though, with Trident. I mean, we saw
De Palo in Silverstone
Yeah, I don't know if maybe a Camara thing could be, but what I'm saying is that I
think it will be fascinating how two drivers that should definitely fight for the title
will line up there, especially if Trident is struggling more than they did previously,
where it was like they were clearly the fastest.
And now I'd argue that in some rounds, at least it looked like Campos was stronger.
And meanwhile, in the third seat,
Maccagnani seems to be rumoured.
I'm going to be honest, he may be rumoured, but that's if he's intelligent.
I could also see him go f*ck it all. I'm doing F2 instantly. I can imagine it.
He has tested F2.
Yeah, like he could do it.
He'd be our AIX second seat. He's the perfect contender for it.
But I feel like if Trident is the sensible idea that you probably should do if you're
trying to actually get somewhere in motorsports and don't just blow through all your money.
Yeah, and it's always a question if De Palo does stay, but given the season he's had,
I would not be surprised if he dropped from a flower and maybe gave to a team to lower
down the grid.
I think Campos is quite fascinating because I do believe that they could become the fastest
team or the fastest car in the next season.
Simultaneously, we've seen quite a few rumours about the team going on
that make it uncertain because obviously we are not the only ones who see it.
It's also the drivers that see it.
So there's like 10 drivers rumoured to be driving Campos.
But I think most certain is Colnaghi, who I'm going to be honest, I did not really have
on my radar before going into the season, but he's been showing up perfectly.
He's been picking up everything that he needed to do.
I've seen a lot of people, maybe a bit biased, but saying he should be one that should really
be in a title fight, especially if he is with campus because he has the experience,
he has the Red Bull support.
There should be something.
Yeah, so Campos lineup appears to be Colnaghi, which Red Bull, as we've mentioned before,
Campos is the Red Bull junior team.
And I think, I mean, given how you've said Campos, they seem to be the stronger team.
Also, he has the advantage of a year of experience next year.
He's going to be the title favourite.
I don't know if he's going to be a title favourite because I know everything.
I know that if you don't have the money and the support, you can literally do everything
and it still won't matter.
But I think he's a driver that has really, you know, made his,
I don't know, the opinion people have of him better.
And alongside him, Hanna has money, so he's still in the second seat.
And the third seat, it seems to be very heavily rumoured to be Alex Powell, which
a certain Robin @mugellomerchant is very happy about.
Unfortunately, she can't be here today, but I'll just have you all know, she is like
extremely happy about this and definitely has things to say about it.
And wants to tell you, he will be in a title fight.
Other than that, I think there's, you know, the typical things going on.
Like Hitech- was Sano announced already?
Because I swear there's one driver who is announced already.
I don't think anyone officially announced.
No, but it was like so definitely announced that.
Yeah, I think that might have been Sano that was like practically confirmed,
but just not- no team announcement is what we'll say.
Yeah, I mean, as you get the pipeline,
Racing in Japan, going to R-ace in FREC, Hitech F3, Hitech F2.
I mean, it seems that it works for, you know, the team sponsors, so I'm not going to complain.
And alongside him, Al Azhari, which seems to be one of the guys who,
I don't think it's fully been rumoured, but it makes sense.
He's been with Hitech in EC3, he's been doing decently.
Going to give my opinion here.
I don't think we will see quite a nice grid where everyone's like graduating.
We will see stupid returnees.
We will see people who are only here for the money.
And, you know, that's what's to be expected.
I think someone like Al Azhari would still be my preferred choice to
compare to what we've seen some drivers do in the last few years,
but we're going to see sooner or later.
I think Van Amersfoort Racing has become a solid team.
So it's kind of a mixed thing that Al Dhaheri  is really rumoured with him,
with them, because simultaneously I would have expected him to,
again, gun for a seat in a really championship winning team.
But if he has the money, he could do the decision to, you know,
do a cheap year in Van Amersfoort and then hope to do a second season
in a stronger team where he, you know, has the experience
and potentially does not have to drive against guys like Sebastian Weldon,
who also have like huge, you know, support.
That's my assumption for him.
And if you look at his record, he seems to be okay with doing
the two-year stints in each championship.
So if he already knows his, you know, patterns.
I remember his first FRECA season was not that, you know, good.
And if he's saying, you know, he's fine.
I think he's also one of the older guys, but he's like 20 or so.
I think if he's fine with, you know, doing that
and maybe securing a long-lived career elsewhere,
that's, I don't know, it's a good choice in my eyes.
Better than rushing through.
I'm pretty sure Rashid is only my age.
So he's still, he's fine.
Yeah. And alongside him, it'll probably be Enzo Deligny continuing on another year.
It's what's been rumored which.
It makes sense.
He can probably build in a VAR.
They've had pace at some rounds as well.
So I mean, it's just one of those drivers where I'm like, yeah, it'll happen.
But I don't think there's a lot to, with all due respect,
I don't think there's a lot of like fans reporting
or things because they're like so interested the same way we see with
KNB and Wheldon’s every move.
I think other than that, we've had some, you know,
actually we've had quite a few rumors and stuff going on for three.
Yeah. The third driver could be anyone.
Like, again, like it's going to be somebody coming,
he could go from F4 to F3.
Somebody else stepping up, changing teams.
We don't fully know for a lot of these teams.
It's quite hard to predict or even the rumors.
The other big rumor is Olivieri, Olivieri with ART.
Also the rumors that Audi and Academy and other teams are interested in him.
This may help him find an F3 seat,
because I think he has struggled with funding as well.
It's the French. They always struggle with money.
He's French, right?
He's Italian.
Oh, okay. He's not French. I'm sorry.
He's spiritually French to me.
He races with R-ace
He looks French.
I think Evan’s also said that.
Olivieri, Emmanuel.
Emmanuel could also be a French name as well.
That's so embarrassing. Please cut that.
No, we're keeping it. Comedy moment.
There's like two drivers that I always mix up,
because I always think like, is Enzo Deligny French?
Enzo's half French, correct.
Okay, so then I mix these two up. Okay, sorry, sorry.
Enzo's Wasian.
Yeah, so the rumors have been going for a bit longer
that Audi has been at some,
I think it was FREC rounds where I heard it.
Well, at the first FREC rounds where he did,
he stalled at both races.
But wasn't there also rumors that,
no, I don't think it was rumors.
I think it was someone in like the YouTube live chat
who was like, yeah, I work at Audi.
And, you know, I usually don't take it serious,
but sometimes I like to imagine things.
They're like, yeah, they're also looking at,
you know, Ninovic, who’s also not doing great.
But who knows, who knows?
Yeah, speaking of Ninovic,
won't be surprised if he goes to Rodin.
I mean, I think Rodin and FREC,
I think part of it is just Rodin being a new team in FREC
because he has stolen pace at times.
Isn't he close to a race ban?
Oh yeah, he is.
Wait, yeah, Ninovic, he has like nine points right now,
nine penalty points or something.
But besides from that, he's been doing pretty well.
Besides, besides, that's horrible.
That sounds horrible, I'm sorry.
But what I'm going to say is that I find when we look back,
I don't know if it's founded, but in my vibe,
Rodin is a team that often has drivers
who are like returning to the team and staying with the team.
And it's like, I assume it's just a really homey vibe
and they have a good vibe going on with the drivers.
So I could see that happening.
As always, Prema is still a thing, even if they don't perform.
So they use quite some rumours.
Of course, we may see Egozi continue on with them.
But there also, we'll get onto his rumours later though,
but there are rumours of him going into IndyNXT,
which could be interesting.
And then, I mean, we have Hector D'Angelo from EC3
also rumoured to go race with Prema.
Dall’Agnol.
Oh my god, I can't say this guy's name right, can I?
It's okay.
I'm sorry.
Hector Dall’Agnol from Palou Motorsports.
And then Perard again, it's basically the Palou Motorsports guys
and then Garfias repeating the year.
I mean, yeah, Prema downfall is real,
when you look at their line-ups.
I feel like at least this year, they still have some,
look at that, they have, they basically have KNB.
And then it's going to get like next year,
they're going to have literally nobody.
It's just a bit depressing to think about,
like three years ago where they were compared to now.
We can't always talk about the same things.
We have to talk about AIX where I read rumours
that Barrichello had signed a one plus one year contract,
which, I mean, I get it, but I also kind of don't
because I do not remember him doing anything really this season.
I mean, the AIX are usually quite in the back.
I think Brad Benavides got us hopeful last year
that maybe they can become, you know, a serious team
and I never know if it's the driver or
if it's the car that's struggling.
I mean, we will see Brad returning from injury.
He should be back.
Yeah, but I don't know.
Like will he do F3 again?
Have there been rumours that he will do F3 again?
Because even if he finishes this season,
like his career has been so ****
and I'm really sorry for him kind of, but.
But he's raced in F2, maybe he goes back to F2.
I mean, if we see him in F2,
I think it will be quite like the story
that he's managed to, you know, finds a way back.
But I'm just kind of, I never know what's going on at AIX.
Either ways, I don't know if it's a sensible thing
to sign a one plus one year contract
because the idea of signing a contract that ensures
if your first F3 season doesn't go to plan,
you can, you know, return is a good thing.
But do you want to do that with AIX?
Yeah.
Because I feel like,
and like I don't really look out for Barrichello.
I feel like if I were him and this season's ****,
you know, but we also expected that
because he was coming from like,
was it EuroFormula Open?
Yeah, a lot of the,
basically the guys who aren't so good have come from EFO.
Either ways, so you come from EuroFormula Open,
you don't have the same,
like EuroFormula Open also drives some circuits,
but it's a different experience
and if you were to drive FREC, you come there,
you're in a bad team and like,
you know, for the first year,
just gaining experience is probably fine.
But if you really want to perform
and your goal is still to, you know,
really go somewhere,
not just waste money having fun driving,
I would have tried to get a better seat.
You know, I'm not saying like Campos or Trident,
but I'm saying like, you know,
maybe Van Amersfoort, maybe ART,
like those, maybe Rodin,
and like those teams that are not
fighting for the championship,
but you know that they can at least get points.
And I heard that they,
the other AIX guys,
whoever's with them right now,
they're looking to repeat the year.
Yeah, I think moving on to FREC now,
because thinking where things get more interesting,
I feel like there's nothing too
out of the blue in F2 and F3,
but FREC, I mean, I think the big thing is DVL.
I would say there's already been some early testing,
FREC, with a bunch of drivers.
Not just DVL,
but I feel like it's really important to mention that we have,
and I called that last year,
we're going to have like Avengers Endgame of Racing,
because you have all of these incredibly talented,
great drivers coming from F4,
because we had a really, really strong F4 field at the moment.
It has been so spread out.
We've had guys in British,
Italian,
Spanish, all of these guys,
we're going to probably see all the F4,
you know, Spanish F4,
British F4,
and Italian F4 champion,
all fighting each other,
E4 champion.
But also not just the champions,
we also have certain drivers that while
maybe at the moment not quite able to be up to the championship fight,
will be more able to get closer,
and I think will be able to use their experience
and prove themselves further in,
you know, FREC,
because I think we don't just have like one or two drivers
for every championship, we’ll have,
We’ll have a really mixed grid.
I think that's great.
Yeah, the thing with DVL that I find interesting.
Interesting, he's been testing with a bunch of different teams.
Of course, you've had quite a few kind of early tests
where a bunch of drivers have been testing.
But DVL, he's tested with always MP, Rodin,
but no matter what team he's been with,
he's been like the quickest.
I thought that he was like six tenths faster than anyone else.
It was some crazy sh*t like that.
Of course, you know, it's only testing,
yada, yada, yada,
but boy, this is going to be fun to see.
And this R-ace lineup, probably DVL,
and most likely, I mean,
Kenzo’s not tested with them,
but Mercedes, R-ace.
DVL and Kenzo Craigie in the same team is going to be fun.
Oh, I can't wait.
Grids not even confirmed.
And really seeing, I mean,
Kenzo is really coming to his own,
like especially in E4.
He's been doing really well,
and especially in the IF4,
maybe R-ace haven't been up to standards, but.
But they're really more up there in FREC.
I mean, these two guys going against each other
is going to be so much fun.
I think we're going to see rivalries form
that we will generally see all the way through F1.
Like, I really think that we were going to see
some absolute bangers.
They're probably going to see Rocco Coronel,
stepping up from Spanish F4,
who's incredibly exciting as well.
And we did get a preview,
and of course, in the Formula Winter Series.
And of course, [?].
I quite like Scott Lindblom as well.
Okay, maybe he's not as hyped up as the other three,
but I think he's,
I really like his race craft a lot.
I saw tested with both CL and Van Amersfoort,
which made me think that,
and what I expect of a lot more drivers to do like him,
you have certain drivers
who really have a lot more funds like DVL.
I like him, but we cannot ignore that.
He apparently really has the money.
So he has the ability to test.
It's like with Freddie, some drivers,
tjhey’re incredibly talented,
but money goes such a long way.
Yeah, but what I wanted to say about him,
like he's been able to test with like every high team,
and he will be able to choose
which team he likes the best
and which team he feels the most comfortable with
and which team he thinks has the best performance.
Well, you have someone like Lindblom,
who, you know, maybe does not have
just quite as much money and instead has,
it looks to me that his strategy is probably more
with also doing CL,
which is like, you know, rather small team,
like not up in the championship fight.
Um, at least get, you know,
a bit of time in the car
and probably to a lot better price
than what he would get if he were to test with R-ace.
I think one that, or two drivers
that I really think are really interesting
that I am hoping for is,
it's kind of expected
that Alp Aksoy is going to return with Prema.
Um. I remember, I remember the start of the season,
there were rumors of him going straight to F3
because of keeping on the F3 calendar next year.
Yeah, I also thought of that just right now
because he could do both
and I really hope he does FREC instead
because I think going straight to F3
could, you know, potentially ruin his career
and I think he's better off putting himself,
you know, in conversation with, maybe not DVL
because I think we won't see a driver
who has just the money
and the ability,
because I both rate him as a great driver
but also he has the money.
But I think Aksoy is doing himself not a favor
if he tries to go up against drivers
like Wheldon and KNB.
Even, even if he could maybe match them driving wise,
they have years of experience on him
and they have, you know, teams backing them,
huge sponsors.
So I think doing FREC would be the wise choice for him.
Yeah, and like speaking of going F4 to F3,
Fionn McLaughlin, that has not worked out for him at all
and now, like, there are rumors
he's going to be dropped from Red Bull.
We don't even know if he's going to be
fully on the F3 grid next year.
I'll argue for him that, you know,
Italian F4 still is closer to F3 than British F4
is, simply because, you know,
Italian F4 has that mainland Europe.
I don't know, it's hard to explain
but circuits like Monza and Imola
and where, you know, Italian F4 regularly drives,
and they didn't this year,
but they have done before like Red Bull Ring
or, you know, other circuits around.
Spa is closer to what you can expect in F3
than what British F4 does
because British F4 technically only has Silverstone.
And British F4, although I think the top level is great,
it also has a lot of midfield drives
where opposed to that in Italian F4,
you always have incredible drivers.
There's another driver that I care for
that I wanted to bring up with Aksoy
is Ary Bansal who has been testing
sometimes with Trident.
And while I have not heard any, you know,
official things stating that he would do it with Trident,
I would not be surprised if that came out to be true.
You know, it makes sense.
Yeah, of course, I reckon we'll see Bondarev on the grid somewhere.
Of course, there's the news that he's now leaving
Italian F4 for the rest of the season
and he's going to, I think it's CL Motorsport into FREC.
So, I mean, he could really be anywhere on the grid next year.
Just because he's with CL now
doesn't mean he'd be with them next year, but.
I saw someone say that CL is a great move by him
to, you know, learn the vibes and, you know,
he's been struggling in F4 and I think it makes more sense
to, you know, get to know the car a bit
and rather drive from the back than trying to be in the front
and, you know, making everything harder for yourself.
And if you get a few rounds down, you have the vibes of the car.
Since apparently that's not something
that has worked out with him so far.
Then next year, once he has a bit of experience,
going to a better team, but also I'm worrying
how much money he even, you know, has.
And I've seen people bring up that we don't know how serious
Williams is still interested in supporting him
when you have someone like KNB who came into the academy after him.
I'm pretty sure, you have to correct me here
but I'm pretty sure started F4 after him.
Um, KNB started the year before.
Did he?
Yeah.
Yeah, KNB’s first year was 2024.
First full year.
Bondarev did a few races to the end of 2024.
Then Kean got dropped by Alpine.
Then 2025, they're both in IF4.
Then it started this year.
Kean goes up to FREC and joins Williams this year,
I think it was.
Yeah, so thank you for this correction
because I just remembered both of them being there for 24
and I was not sure about 23.
Either way, in any way, the fact that Kean will be in F3
while Bondarev will only have to try to get even anywhere in
FREC, does not seem good for, you know, him.
And I'm pretty sure that Williams doesn't,
don't they have like 10-year-olds in their karting team lining up?
Oh, they have Hoogendoorn, which has been very strong in USF.
So yeah, and then Palacio and Green who are going up to OK.
Yeah, and we're going to probably see Hoogendoorn in F4 somewhere next year.
He's only doing USF as he's not 15 yet.
Yeah, that's kind of the point where I'm thinking, you know,
maybe they decide that, you know, supporting Bondarev is not the way anymore.
Either way, I saw Bearman tested with Van Amersfoort
and I expect him to move up.
Even, you know, if, I don't know, he's not the most interesting driver to me.
I think he's just kind of there, but he definitely has the money for it.
And weirdly enough, Van Amersfoort was also,
from what I remember, a team that had his brother raced with before.
So I guess- Ollie won, he won Italian F4 with Van Amersfoort.
Yeah, I think, you know, that's just how it goes sometimes.
One team that's interesting to me, and that's specifically me,
is obviously the woman involvement at Rodin.
Rodin has been testing with Abbi Pulling,
who I would love to see race in, because she's been in GB3.
But the thing in GB3 is she's been very unlucky for really sh*tty reasons.
Like, was there a chassis crack last year or some sh*t like that?
Either way, she was unlucky.
GB3, again, the top, I really rate some of the drivers
and like the top five drivers of GB3.
But we've seen it with Louis Sharp, who went from GB3 to F3,
and really struggled in his first year.
And I think that's what, was Ninovic, who went to FREC after GB3,
now, you know, seems more prepared for F3 next year?
Yes, yeah, he did GB3 last year.
Yeah, and he's in FREC, and he's, you know, doing very well,
because he had experience in faster cars.
But, you know, maybe lacking a bit of experience on European circuits.
Either way, Abbi Pulling is a driver.
I would also just love to see a bit of female involvement again.
You know, and much more importantly, and what everyone should expect from me is
Rodin has also been testing with Alisha Palmowski.
And I've been told by someone who I trust as a source,
that currently there are no real, you know, discussions for race going on,
because FREC is really expensive.
And if you know Alisha Palmowski, she is very unlucky with sponsors.
Like, she does not have millions to blow every single year.
And sometimes there is no, you know, current discussion.
It could become a thing later on when it's about the F1 Academy sponsoring a seat.
I would absolutely love that.
And I think it would be the greatest thing in the world.
They need to bring that back.
I think I have it in my heart.
They will, because, you know, last year was a bit weird with, you know,
Doriane Pin winning, but, you know, not really wanting,
and not really having a worth in continuing single seaters.
All that drama.
I think this year we have a group of, you know, the leading drivers.
I also expect to see Emma Felbermayr and Nina Gademan in a seat,
not in FREC, but potentially in GB3.
Nina Gademan has recently mentioned in an interview,
being interested in doing Eurocup 3 with MP.
I could see that happening.
And for Palmowski, what's important for me is that she's been doing it with Rodin,
which I think is really good because it means to me that there is
some sort of conversation between her and the team.
And even if it's not FREC, I would really hope for like GB3
or anything in like that range of things.
Yeah, I really do-
I mean, she should step up and they should bring the prize back.
She deserves to step up and alongside them.
But imagine getting two women in the same team.
I think it would be great.
You're going to become the biggest Rodin fan then next year.
I'm going to.
Like Rodin is New Zealand-ish, no?
I'm going to buy like really big New Zealand flag.
If a woman goes to FREC, I'm going to try to do multiple FREC rounds.
I'm going to call it now.
I mean, they're probably going to be in Hockenheim.
Like in Hockenheim, they'll probably be in Spa again.
Zandvoort.
Are they doing Zandvoort?
Because I would try to do Zandvoort also.
And Red Bull Ring.
That's like the four circuits that I would love to do.
And I could realistically do.
Yeah, Alex's FR tour.
Alex's FREC tour.
Okay, either way.
We also had Lennon testing with Rodin again.
That Rodin family stuff is strong, you know.
I think, I mean, DVL tested with them as well.
I think the only reason he'll go to R-ace,
and not Rodin-
DVL has been generally testing with every f*cking single team
to decide which one is best for him.
It's a bit creepy.
Yeah, which is probably why R-ace makes the most sense.
He's just spying on them in the night.
He's just laying there in the factory spying.
No, it's like, you know, when, you know, like,
these really super rich people can just do whatever.
That's kind of creepy to me, honestly.
Anyways, anyways, anyways.
Going on to other series, as we mentioned earlier.
James Egozi is rumored for IndyNXT.
Which, I mean, we've seen, we saw-
Wait a second, I just remembered something.
We need to go back.
Oh my God.
I know I missed something.
And that is that some driver from Brazilian F4
has mentioned on the stream that he has signed a contract race
in F4 next, not F4, in F3 next year.
That's important.
Needed to mention that one.
Needed to get this one off my chest.
I just remembered.
This is probably going to be an AIX driver.
Oh, that would make sense.
Yeah, probably.
But like, it's important for me to mention it.
I should probably research who it was, but I'm too lazy.
So if you see a Brazilian driver coming straight from F4,
I knew it, I knew it.
You heard it here first.
It's also inviting listeners to do their own research.
Anyways.
Egozi rumored for IndyNXT.
I mean, I could honestly see this working quite well for him,
Cause of course,
We have the Polish guy, Tymek.
The Polish guy.
Kucharczyk.
He's the one I'm talking about.
Yeah, him.
He's in IndyNXT and he's doing quite well.
And he came from like EFO or something.
And Egozi is an EC3 championship-
he's the EC3 championship leader.
He's going to win the championship.
It's inevitable he's going to win it.
I feel like we could see him do quite well.
And of course, being an American, maybe he's targeting IndyCar.
So I feel like that would really make quite a bit of sense.
Isn't he also Spanish or something like that?
He races under the American flag.
Oh.
He races for-.
He races with Palou Motorsport.
No, I was just vibing with the idea of someone racing us with Palou Motorsport and maybe
even getting the attention in Spain by Spanish supporters who also like Palou and kind of
stepping into his footsteps and all of that stuff.
He's American.
He's born in Florida.
Also, just look up his Wikipedia.
Look at his Wikipedia.
He has a really...
This guy has an interesting Wikipedia photo.
Look it up.
To be fair, his first name is Luis.
Like L-U-I-S.
James is his middle name.
I thought it was James.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Oh God.
We've been living a lie.
What is that Wikipedia picture?
What?
He's straight up sharking it.
Okay, that's insane.
I wonder, where did this photo come from?
His Instagram story.
How does that happen?
Find it.
Either way, he's spiritually Spanish to me.
Maybe it's just because he's been racing so much in Spain
that I automatically just think of him as Spanish.
Yeah, unfortunately, we don't have any photos in this,
but if you are listening, do look up James Egozi’s Wikipedia.
That's beautiful.
Go be amused.
Especially if you're having a bad day, please go find it.
Either way, that's enough.
That's enough.
Now looking towards F4.
Noah Baglin is going to be stuff.
He's confirmed he'll be doing F4 next year.
I think it's Italian F4.
We just don't know with what team.
I mean, maybe Prema given FDA, but...
But I thought Ferrari hated Prema now.
But Maccagnani is Ferrari.
Yeah, I just wanted to say,
it's like another guy who's now again with Prema.
I think Prema is still pretty strong in Italian F4.
So, you know what, I think we could also see him
depending on how much money he has, in US Racing
because it's all just pay to win.
Yeah, maybe, I mean, Trident have been looking good here, maybe.
Who knows, you can probably see James and...
That's not how you spell his last name.
It's Anagnostiadis.
Yeah, he'd be with R-ace.
Wait, I need to spell out how it's written here.
It's written as Anagonditadias.
Who wrote that?
That wasn’t me, and I think Robin though.
There's someone who misspelled so many names on here.
Someone also misspelled Rocco Coronel as Rocco Connell.
And I was so confused who you're talking about.
I was worried that this would be very badly done, but it's okay.
But Anagonditadias, that's crazy.
He would be with R-ace, because Mercedes and R-ace are besties now.
But interestingly, the other Ferrari karting driver who's stepping up,
Filippo Sala, he's moving to Spanish F4.
How is that allowed? Wow.
Yeah, Spanish F4.
What even happens in Spanish-
Like, genuinely, one of the biggest points of criticism that I've seen
and that I've heard of drivers is that since Spanish F4 drives without good tires,
it makes it harder to do like...
I heard it from Emma Felbermayr who complained because in F1 Academy
and in British F4, they're driving Pirelli tires,
which feel very different to what she drove in Spanish F4,
which is why she decided to not do Spanish F4 again,
because she felt like it was so stupid.
And I'm just wondering why he would go to Spanish F4 then,
especially if you're a Ferrari Academy member.
He's also Italian.
Why are you? I just thought maybe he's Spanish
and that's why he's wanting to stay in his glorious homeland.
No, what? Why is he going to Spain?
He's Ferrari and he's Italian.
You would expect him to continue on into Italian F4.
All I can think of is probably just funding.
I mean, alright, you know, maybe, maybe Ferrari doesn't give any money at all,
but just like Spanish F4, man.
Or what I could imagine is if you know,
like Noah Baglin is, you know, doing Italian F4 already
and maybe Ferrari wants to split it up
like the way we've had it split up with all the good drivers in F4 this year,
where they're all in different things.
So they can, you know, do their own thing
and not have that huge rivalry from their first ever race on,
which would obviously impact how they drive each other.
And like both of them drive for their own title.
And if they have like a bit of confidence, a bit of experience,
also their own sponsors,
put them together in FREC, or you separate them for longer.
And you can also make the decision better
than whom of the two you want to support long term
because Ferrari supporting two guys,
that are basically in the same championship
is not something that we see often of them.
Yeah, a little thing now, the F1 Academy.
I want to say F1 Academy, can I say F1 Academy?
Of course, I can leave it to you.
Of course.
Thank you.
Okay, so we need to go in because there's a lot of things.
Not a lot of things we expect, a lot of things are rumored.
Most notably rumored, and this one's really just a rumor,
but everyone expects it so heavily,
I'm really going to be surprised if it doesn't happen,
is that Larson returns with Ferrari.
If you are confused now
because F1 Academy has a two year limit,
yeah, kind of, no, because last year they announced
that if everyone felt it was appropriate,
a driver could do a third season.
That's generally something that a lot of drivers
who are in their second season now, including Nina Gademan,
or Emma Felbermayr I have talked kind of about
in the way it's like, no, they're not even considering it,
which I think is a good thing.
The thing is, Alba Larson is currently like ninth
in the championship.
She's in the middle of her second season.
She has not had a single podium in F1 Academy.
I mean, she did one in British F4,
but since she is becoming more and more kind of the face
of F1 Academy, if you ask someone
who does not watch F1 Academy to name a driver,
everyone's going to name her because she's popular.
She's the Instagram follower.
She's always doing something.
There are many people who expect Ferrari
to not care about her driving,
and instead just care about not having to give a big f*ck
about who they would support.
So it's expected she will return.
Another one which is heavily expected or almost announced
is Ginevra Panzeri, who has scored the VCARB support
with Campos.
Ginevra Panzeri has been driving like every single F4 series this year.
She's been in French F4, Central European Zone F4,
I think even Italian F4.
She's been everywhere.
I think the main reason where this came up was in French F4
where one weekend she had a really good one
and she was like P7 and P6.
And it was really rainy.
It was really rainy and there were multiple rumors
of also Alpine looking at her.
But from everything we heard so far,
it's pretty certain that VCARB locked her down,
which with Campos, if we see their performance this year,
is a good choice.
It's genuinely expected that most drivers
in like their first year, including like Matilda Paatz
Lisa Billard, Megan Bruce, that they’ll all return.
It's kind of a bit more of a difficult thing,
but I don't want to go into detail about every single driver.
It's just like most drivers just do a second season.
For most of them, it makes sense.
We also expect to see the wildcards return,
except for Shi Wei because no one knows who Shi Wei even is.
Not as a reason no one knows.
It's the fact that we still don't know her age,
which is kind of weird.
But it's really expected that Chiara Bättig
will be with Red Bull, with Campos,
and fight for the championship.
There is a big chance that Luna Fluxa
will be a wildcard later this season.
I think Las Vegas was what people assumed.
And that she would go on to maybe come in
because she's a Mercedes junior.
We have Peyton Westcott currently as Mercedes junior,
so we're going to see.
But it will also be interesting because...
Oh, Ella Hakkinen will turn 16 as far as I know in December.
So there's a big chance that we will also see her
take over Ella Lloyd's McLaren seat.
Other than that, it's still kind of unsure
whom of the wildcards and whom of other drivers coming in.
Like Jordyn Martin, who's currently the best female in GB4,
which gives you a certain sponsorship
of like 50,000 pounds or something like that.
We have a handful of drivers who we expect to see.
And of those handful of drivers we expect to see,
it's still kind of unclear where...
What's the word… sponsors for?
Like Alpine will be free again.
We have a few brands who will be free to support someone else again.
I think that's something that we will discuss in a few months again, maybe.
Yeah, I think that's all that I have to say about women.
Alba Larson doing another third year would be incredibly interesting.
I mean, I don't think she's got any podiums or anything.
It's just a marketing thing it honestly feels like.
I'm just sorry for her and I always say it like that because,
I feel like she's been done wrong by so many people around her because
every single time that I see other drivers like testing cars,
going to other championships, the only thing that I really see of her
is that either she's part of some fashion campaign
or that she's doing some, you know, out of the car thing for women.
I know she's recently had this karting event with a lot of girls
and support girls get their first kart raced, which is a great thing for her.
And I'm pretty sure that's a great thing for the woman involved.
But the thing is, her own career just seems to be
like the last thought anyone has really in mind because I know she also does one-off races.
She did some one-off races like two or three in British F4 and I was at Zandvoort.
I like seeing her there.
I just wish that she did majority of that season the way that like
Emma Felbermayr is doing one-off entries in British F4, but she’s also doing multiple races in Italian F4.
There's other drivers, even if they're not racing, like Nina Gademan,
who was mentioned testing EC3 cars with MP before.
Those so many things really matter and that's also things that I think
will keep her even after her third season from in any way improving on her abilities
and gaining another seat.
I feel like beyond that, I don't have too much else to say.
I mean, although in EC3, Gino Trappa has said he's competing in another year of EC3.
Aside from that, because in F4 we normally find out incredibly late.
I mean, F4 always kind of depends on how the season went for the drivers themselves
and then you also have karting drivers and for them it's...
I mean, F4 depending on the championship can be super expensive,
but sometimes these kids have very little sponsors and it's all really dramatic.
So we're going to see.
I hope that we manage to do another episode later in the season
where we can maybe discuss a few of these things,
look back on the rumors, discuss the upcoming grids.
But I think other than that.
I think that is all for this week.
Join us next time as we will discuss
British F4 finally returning to racing.
With summer break over, with British F4 and F1 Academy returning this upcoming weekend.
So join us then and as always, let us know your thoughts and comments.
We love hearing from you guys.
And yeah. Thank you for listening.